les les les révoltes ces révoltes-l sont
ont aussi une dimension
ludique ont aussi une dimension ludique
qui est présente c'est-à-dire que la
révolte la colère l'indignation ces
mobilisations n'empêchent pas de rendre
l'exercice ludique alimenté par des
formes d'excitation de compétition
horifique d'adrénaline euh euh de de de
de d'alimenter une forme de sentiment
d'exister à travers l'engagement dans
les rival dans dans les dans les dans
les dans les émeutes et dans les
révoltes et tout ça est amplifié par ce
que permettent les outils numériques
aujourd'hui
euh et euh ce qui m'a quand même frappé
euh les outils numériques euh permettent
de viraliser de diffuser euh euh et
d'accéter à des formes de gratification
euh assez importantes euh tout en
manifestant sa colère les choses ne sont
pas à à opposer en fait c'est pas soit
l'un soit l'autre ça peut être l'un et
l'autre si on veut vraiment comprendre
les les formes d'engagement moi j'ai été
frappé par la multiplication notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux sur snapchat sur
TikTok ou d'autres vecteurs euh
numérique comme cela j'ai été frappé par
le nombre de de fausses vidéos par
exemple c'est-à-dire des jeunes qui ont
pris qui ont chopé des vidéos sur
internet des des vidéos qui sont
spectaculaires et qui ont accollé
pendant cette période làà le nom de leur
quartier ou le nom de leur ville donc on
a vu des vidéos lié au avec des espèces
de de de pseudo tireur d'élite sur un
toit euh euh quelqu'un avec un bazooka
euh des armes de guerre mais des armes
lourdes euh des vidéos extrêmement
spectaculaires et puis une petite
vérification permettait de se rendre
compte que c'était les vidéos qui
avaient été chopées en Syrie euh pendant
la guerre civile de chopé euh en
Amérique latine et cetera et et cette
démarche là montre bien à quel point la
compétition honorifique est quelque
chose qui s'est quand même greffé euh
euh à cette à ce qui s'est passé fin
juin début juillet